es ist juli der gemüsegarten explodiert
und deswegen schauen wir uns jetzt mal
an was draußen erledigt werden muss
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht aber
meine tomaten legen gerade richtig los
und wenn ich nicht absolut hinterher bin
dann verwandelt sich mein gewächshaus
innerhalb von ein paar tagen in einen
dschungel deswegen jetzt auf jeden fall
anders aus zu denken das bedeutet dass
man die seitentriebe die sich in den
blattachseln bilden bei den tomaten
ausbricht so dass man die einträge
erziehen kann das macht man nicht mit
allem tomaten aus tomaten kann man
wuchern lassen wie sie wollen aber die
allermeisten tomaten sollte man
ausreiten damit die pflanzen gesund
bleiben damit luft zwischen den
zirkulieren kann damit die schneller
abtrocknen auch damit man die früchte
besser findet ich habe mal ein jahr
meine tomaten gar nicht ausgereizt die
sind zwar gigantisch geworden aber ich
bin überhaupt nicht mehr durchgedrungen
durch den dschungel wenn ihr nicht so
genau wissen wie es geht und schaut
gerne mal unten in die video
beschreibung dafür danke ich euch ein
video mit einer anleitung zum aussetzen
bei den kunden gerade bei den
gewächshaus gurken sollte man die
seitentriebe auch entfernen da seht ihr
den haupt von willen gehen auch
seitentriebe ab und wenn ihr die hoch
bilden volt und eintönig erzielen wollt
dann macht das total sind die
seitentriebe zu entfernen damit die
pflanze die kraft in diesem antrieb
statt an denen es ist schön viele große
früchte wachsen kann es gibt
gemüsepflanzen die sind viel hungriger
als andere dinge man stark zu dazu
zählen zum beispiel die tomaten und die
gurken aber auch zb der kohl gerade
diese stark zehra wollen den sommer über
immer mal wieder mit flüssigdünger
versorgt werden über das gießwasser der
wird nämlich superschnelle also noch am
selben tag merkt die pflanze dass der
dünger da ist und deswegen denkt daran
dass er jetzt auch meine prämisse auch
an setzt dafür einbringen
lücken in einen eimer mit wasser
bedecken und jeden tag umrühren das
ganze natürlich abdecken damit er keine
insekten oder mäuse rein fallen und so
könnt ihr euch euren eigenen
flüssigdünger herstellen ansonsten fällt
natürlich auch biologische fährte dünger
kaufen da gibt es verschiedene ich
benutze ganz gerne wie nasse oder auch
melasse und ich bin euch hier nochmal
eine liste ein mit den pflanzen die zu
den stark zählern brillen und die jetzt
ganz gerne meine dünger ladung über
schließt wasser bekommen möchten viele
gemüse pflanzen wie zum beispiel der
salat oder der spüle hat der kohl der
jetzt im zweiten jahr im beet steht oder
bei mir jetzt auch der auch die wollen
jetzt pflanzen babys machen sie wollen
sich vermehren und wenn ihr lust habt
eure eigenen gemüsesorten in eurem
garten zu vermehren dann fängt jetzt
auch die samen ernten dafür wartet ihr
bis die blüten verblüht sind an euren
gemüsepflanzen und die samen richtig
schönen rasche trocken sind auf jeden
fall schauen dass ihr das eventuell
nochmal nach trocknet im haus damit ihr
das richtig schön trocken in die gläser
abgefüllt und sich das ganze auch hält
er ein paar jahre dann auch freude an
irgendeinem bad wenn ihr lust hat meter
weg zu lernen wir haben ein idiot
erstellt zusammen gärtnerei das könnt
ihr euch den runterladen kostet auch
nicht viele der link ist und dass wir
beschreiben viele pflanzen wie zum
beispiel die tomaten oder paprika oder
wirklich brauchen ein bisschen
unterstützung weil die sonst einfach
umkippen man kann auch einfach über den
boden wachsen lassen das ist auch kein
problem aber ich habe sehr viel bessere
erfahrungen gemacht haben wir die
irgendwo hochranken zu lassen im
gewächshaus finde ich die an schnüren an
genauso wie die tomaten das ist super
praktisch da immer daran denken dass sie
die pflanzen immer weiter um die sturm
umgekippt damit sie auch weiterhin halt
haben und nicht oben abbrechen und
draußen wenn ich die tomaten zb einer
stange habe da muss ich dir jetzt auch
immer mal wieder anbinden ich machte
einfach eine lockere schleife aus dem
bast der irgendwie verrotten kann damit
der garten ist gerade jetzt nicht
irgendwie den plastikmüll an schleppe
und damit mache ich einfach unter der
taxe lockeren knoten der mit pflanzen am
rand gericht fest gebunden bei paprika
reicht es oft wenn man einfach den
staaten nehmen die pflanzen in die erde
steckt damit die ein bisschen gestützt
ist manchmal kommen die paprika auch
ganz gut ohne stütze aus bei auberginen
ist das ganz genauso starken boden rang
von selber nach oben da muss man
meistens nicht nachhelfen oder nur ganz
am anfang meine sachen lohn bekommen
auch jede mannschaft damit wenig
abnehmen der juli ist der perfekte monat
um knoblauch und zwiebeln zu ehren da
ist es auch ganz wichtig dass man den
richtigen erntezeitpunkt ab passt wenn
zum beispiel der knobloch sonst diese
außenhaut verliert dann werden die
tränen freigelegt und fallen auseinander
der wird auch fällig wenn man den zu
lange im bett stehen lässt deswegen
achtet darauf bis ungefähr zwei drittel
des laubes gelb sind achtet auch darauf
er bei trockenem wetter zu ernten und
man kann bei knoblauch und zwiebeln auch
die äußerste hülle direkt bei der ernte
avastin wo die ganze erde daran klebt da
hat man sehr viel sauberere knollen und
nachdem ich die geerntet habe hängig die
erst mit zum trocknen auf ich mache das
bei mir im gewächshaus man kann das aber
auch an einem haus vorsprung machen es
ist auf jeden fall wichtig wenn man die
lagern möchte und nicht sofort auf essen
möchte dass sie erst mal schönen
durchtrocknen weil du sonst im lager
auch angefangen zu bauen und dafür
bündel ich so ungefähr fünf
knoblauchknollen oder fünf zwiebeln
zusammenhang die dann einfach im
gewächshaus auf so dass die luftig in
der luft baumeln und danach ein paar
wochen können die auch ins lager anderen
kann man auch schöne rezept wird raus
flächen aber ich habe in meinem ersten
oder zweiten gartenjahr dachte ich euch
wir so ein tolles liebe zopf flechten
und habe die zwiebeln grün genommen und
geflochten und das war gar nicht cool
weil das in der mitte von dem kopf dann
ganz schnell angefangen hat zu kehren
und superkräfte stunden hat seitdem
warte ich mit dem flechten besiedeln
einmal richtig durch getrocknet sind
dann klappt das nämlich lieber sagt
generell ist die allergrößte aufgabe die
ihr gerade im garten habt das ernten das
klingt jetzt erst mal banal aber es ist
bei vielen gemüsen gar nicht so einfach
den richtigen die einen zeitpunkt
festzulegen oder zu bestimmten gerade
wenn man das noch nie gemacht hat und
wenn man zum beispiel den courage ewig
lange im bett stehen lässt dann wird er
auch irgendwann holt sich je nach sorte
und so passiert ist das zum beispiel
auch gemüse anfangen zu blühen zum
beispiel der salat fängt irgendwann an
zu schießen oder auch der spinat wir
jetzt blühen wenn man nicht darauf
achtet dass man die rechtzeitig erntet
deswegen hat ein auge auf eure gemüse
und schaut auch mal wann muss man ein
welches gemüse ernten um den perfekten
zeitpunkt abzupassen und mit der großen
ernte schwemmer steht auch das
haltbarmachen an also werden wir diesen
sommer wieder ganz viel einkochen und
fermentieren und auch einlagern deswegen
habe ich jetzt mal geschaut habe ich
dann alles was ich frage zum
haltbarmachen ich habe zum beispiel
gerade noch mal einfach der serbe stellt
weil ich gemerkt habe sind ziemlich
aufgebraucht und deswegen geht mal durch
und schaut ob ihr bereit seid für die
haltbar macht saison und wenn ihr lust
habt darüber mehr zum lernen und zu
lernen wie man richtig schöne super
leckere vorratskammer mit sicher
haltbaren lebensmitteln anlegt dann habe
ich eine gute neuigkeit für euch weil
nämlich vor ein paar tagen mein obst und
gemüse haltbar machen onlinekurs seine
türen wieder geöffnet hat da zeige ich
euch wie das funktioniert die ganzen
techniken zum haltbarmachen das ist ein
videokurs den ihr ganz gemütlich von zu
hause aus durch arbeiten könnt mit ganz
vielen um einen lieblingsrezepten und
auch einer ganz tollen gemeinschaft von
ein koch sucht das macht wahnsinnig viel
spaß also wenn ihr lust habt dabei zu
sein und diese alten techniken zu lernen
dann schaut gerne mal unter diesem link
vorbei oder auch unten in der video
beschreibung der verlinke ich euch den
auch noch mal ein großer wie gesagt
jetzt gerade wieder geöffnet wir haben
wieder freie plätze also schnappt ihr
euch und dann freue ich mich wahnsinnig
wenn wir uns vielleicht im kurs wieder
sehen ich habe jetzt auch gerade mal so
eine bestandsaufnahme in der
vorratskammer gemacht und mal geguckt
wie groß ist denn eigentlich noch da gar
nicht mehr so viel muss ich diese sehr
vielleicht nicht mehr haltbar machen als
letztes jahr das ja aber auch in echten
desto mehr muss man sagen ich glaube
dass du dieses jahr wäre mir ist immer
ganz wichtig dass ich schaue muss ich
dieses jahr vielleicht weniger zum
haltbarmachen weil ich davon einfach
noch so verletzte mehr übrig haben oder
mehr tomatensoße und deswegen habe ich
da jetzt gerade mal so eine kleine
wunschliste erstellt mit sachen die mir
fehlen und auch geschaut wo ich
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger
da machen wir sonst einfach zu viel ja
und dann werde auch schon die erste
marmelade gekocht werden die beeren sind
reich und die ersten verbände werden an
der selbst ich habe auch schon was
fermentiert ich habe schon einige gläser
in meine vorratskammer eingeräumt und
das ist natürlich auch eine richtig
große aufgabe jetzt über die
sommermonate bis in den herbst hinein
ich versuche so zu gärtnern dass ich
möglichst linie gießen muss das
funktioniert auch richtig gut aber nicht
in hochbeeten die trockenen endlich
richtig schnell aus viel schneller als
eben eher die gebiete und deswegen denkt
daran dass ihr eure hochbeete besonders
in den heißen monaten auch ordentlich
dies weil die pflanzen sonst ganz schöne
drin leiden im gewächshaus da regnet
natürlich rein das heißt da sind wir auf
regelmäßiges gießen angewiesen ich dies
immer lieber einmal pro woche richtig
viel so dass das wasser auch in tiefere
bodenschichten gesickert und die
pflanzen nicht nur so ganz oberflächlich
wasser bekommen und dann super abhängig
davon werden dass man immer wieder geht
wenn die tomaten richtig greift sind und
sonst klatschen wenn sie so unregelmäßig
mit wasser versorgt werden das ist
wirklich für die paar monate zu zwei mal
in der woche gießen im gewächshaus aber
öfter die sich nicht dadurch erzielt die
auch dazu dass sie ein bisschen
unabhängiger sind und dann stehe ich
vielleicht auch im sommerurlaub vor der
tür bei euch das ist ja wunderschön aber
denkt daran dass ihr euren garten auch
dementsprechend vorbereitet es gibt drei
ziemlich guten möglichkeiten man kann
zum beispiel das gärtnern die man gerade
in einem hochbeet eingriff es sind
unterirdische wasserspeicher wo das
wasser über eine ton waren die ganz
langsam an die pflanzen abgegeben wird
und dann gibt es ton kegel die kann man
in die erde stecken da kann man dann zum
beispiel eine weinflasche mit wasser
füllen und ungeklärte sind und säge
stecken und das ist genau das gleiche
prinzip aber auch für kleinere räume wie
zb auch bei tontöpfe geeignet und bringt
daran dass ihr euch da vorbereitet denkt
auch daran dass ihr vorher bevor
dort geht einmal alles abgeerntet war
dieses jahr auch zum ersten mal seit
jahren seit ich ein kind bin auch
richtig genommen habe hier steht dann
auf jeden fall eine große haltbar macht
session an weil ich natürlich im sommer
nicht die ganze andere schenken will
wenn ich eine längere zeit weg bin wie
zum thema wasser speichern gehört
natürlich auch das mulchen wenn ihr eure
bild noch nicht gemacht habe oder erst
dünn gemacht habt dann erhöht die mode
auf jeden fall noch mal ein bisschen ich
nehme dafür am liebsten
holzhackschnitzel und rasenschnitt das
ist mir super kombination um auch ein
gutes cn verhältnis ich zu haben einfach
um die pflanzen sobald sie so 10 und 15
zentimeter hoch sind eine ordentliche
mulchschicht verteilen es hilft
wunderbar um auch heiße monate gut zu
überstehen haben wenn ihr unkräuter seht
in ihrem garten da nicht sehr gern an
die sofort rausreißen weil die nämlich
jetzt alle anfangen zu blühen und dann
werden aus einer pflanze schnell mal 100
oder 1000 stück und dem kann man sehr
leicht vorbeugen also sehr gut für faule
leute wenn man eben mal nicht faul ist
sondern diese eine pflanze schnell mal
raus heißt die man entdeckt weil man
sonst nämlich gar nicht mehr
hinterherkommt wenn sie sich einmal aus
samen und genau so solltet ihr auch
darauf aufpassen wenn ihre krankheiten
oder schädlinge in ihrem garten entdeckt
weil es nämlich meistens viel einfacher
ist die zu bekämpfen wenn man es
frühzeitig sieht wenn ihr jetzt raupen
anderem kohl seht dann schaut lieber
dass er sie jetzt ab sammelst du vorher
cool vielleicht in zwei tagen gar nicht
mehr da ist dann vielleicht auch mal
schauen wenn eine tomatenpflanze
irgendwelche komischen roten flecken
bekommt und er nicht so genau wissen was
das ist dass ihr vielleicht mal versucht
herauszufinden was die hatte mit denen
schnell helfen können jetzt ist auch ein
toller zeitpunkt um kräuter zu ernten
die wachsen ja gerade auch wie blöd und
deswegen glück ganz viele kräutersträuße
und hängt gefälligst ein ganzes haus
damit voll dass es erstens zu kuscheln
und zweitens zeigt ihr dann heute
selbstversorger es ist so leicht seine
eigenen kräuter zum kochen selber
anzubauen dafür braucht man nicht mehr
als paar fensterbänke also das geht auf
so einer kleinen fläche und das ist so
ein cooles gefühl wenn man sich in so
einem kleinen bereich irgendwie selbst
versorgen kann bei den meisten kräuter
nüsse vormittags der beste
erntezeitpunkt aber meine güte wenn ihr
erst abends nach hause kommt dann endet
ihre kräuter abend sollte man gar nicht
macht dann einfach kopfüber aus hin zum
trocknen das funktioniert mit den
allermeisten kräutern sehr sehr gut
andere muss man vielleicht einfrieren um
das aroma zu erhalten und dann seid ihr
auf einmal kräuter setzt nur sogar aber
bei all dem ernten und haltbar machen
darf man nicht vergessen dass der juli
ein super wichtiger monat ist um weitere
gemüse aus zu sehen und zwar vor allem
wie gemüse die man im herbst und winter
ernten möchte und es ist nämlich total
schön wenn man auch in der kalten
jahreszeit was aus seinem garten ernten
kann und nicht nur die heute ein koch
gläser hat und deswegen schaut euch
gerne das video da drüben an da zeige
ich euch nämlich welche gemüse man jetzt
im juli pflanzen und säen sollte und
ansonsten geht raus und macht die welt
ein bisschen grüner ich wünsche euch
noch einen wunderschönen tag macht's gut